we've been given the new 24 inch imac a
ton of attention recently because of how
much value it packs for 300
like the new modern design that'll look
great in any room or office
the insanely high quality 4.5 k display
the unbelievably thin chassis the high
quality peripherals
and of course the power and reliability
of the new m1 chip
however even with all of that the m1
macbook air
might actually give you more value
because you get that m1 chip at a lower
price
currently only 950 on amazon if you use
the link below
this creates a problem because each of
these m1 macs have their own advantages
and
disadvantages so it's pretty hard to
figure out which one truly gives you
more value
and that's exactly what i'm gonna answer
in this video
by digging deep into everything
including the design
portability specs and performance so
let's get right into it
starting off with the design the m1
macbook air has the same one that it's
had ever since the 2018 redesign
which came with intel chips in fact when
apple released the m1 air
the only thing they did was replace the
intel chip with the m1 chip
and i think they did that to make a
statement showing how big of a
difference
just one chip can make but then if you
look at the new 24 inch imac
it gets a brand new design that
basically seems
impossibly thin for an all-in-one
computer
with that amount of power packed into it
and with that
it looks incredibly clean modern and
up-to-date
because we know that the last time apple
changed the imac's design
it stayed the same for basically the
next 10 years
so if you buy this 24 inch imac right
now
you don't have to worry about the design
getting outdated anytime soon but with
the m1 macbook air
you're stuck with the design from 2018
and based on recent leaks and rumors
there's a pretty good chance that the
air is getting redesigned within the
next year
which might make this m1 air start to
feel a bit outdated
but don't get me wrong the current
design is great
and it looks amazing and i expect this
m1 air to continue to be sold
alongside the new redesigned model when
it comes out and now moving on to the
ports
they both actually get the same two
thunderbolt ports if you're comparing
the base models
which can definitely be limiting for
those who want more
but with the imac you do have the option
of paying 200
more for the mid-tier model to get an
extra two
regular usb-c ports which is a nice
addition
on top of that that extra cash also gets
you an 8 core gpu instead of 7.
it gets you an ethernet port built into
the power brick
it gets you touch id built into the
magic keyboard
and surprisingly it even gets you a
better cooling system
with two fans and a heat pipe which we
showed off in our full comparison video
which you should definitely check out if
you haven't already so the nice thing
with the imac is that you can pay a
little bit of extra cash
and get some nice upgrades compared to
the m1 macbook air
which only allows you to upgrade to an 8
core gpu
if you pay more so you don't even have
the opportunity
to get more than those two ports so yes
that seems like a bummer
but keep in mind that even if you pay
extra and buy the 1500
24 inch imac you're still stuck with the
same
m1 chip that comes on the m1 macbook air
for only a thousand dollars
or 950 if you're buying it on sale on
amazon using the link below
so because of that the m1 macbook air is
definitely the better value mac
if you're just looking at performance by
itself even though the air is completely
fanless compared to the 24 inch imac
which at least comes with one fan on the
base model
the performance isn't that far off
considering the difference in size
and price so you're definitely getting
some good bang for the buck but keep in
mind that if you pay extra for the 1500
imac you're gonna get much better
cooling performance
which will lead to even better
performance which is a plus
and on top of all of that the 24 inch
imac also has some other advantages over
the air
so let's go ahead and go through all of
them the main one is
the 24 inch display because it's
obviously much larger
allowing you to do things that aren't as
convenient on a smaller
13-inch display for example max took the
m1 macbook air with him on vacation to
hawaii
so he could edit some of the photos that
he took there and he said that the
display was really hard to edit photos
on
because he's used to much larger
displays on top of the fact that the
controls in lightroom take up a lot of
space on the screen
so he definitely wouldn't want to edit
photos full time on the macbook air
but with a 24 inch imac display it's a
lot easier
and on top of that you're working with a
very sharp
4.5 k resolution instead of 2.5 k on the
air
which can help you make more fine-tuned
edits
especially if you're working with large
resolution images
and one thing to know is that the imax
display can get brighter
with up to 500 nits instead of 400 on
the macbook air
on top of that with the larger 24 inch
display it's much easier to multi-task
at the same time by having multiple
windows open side-by-side
which isn't as convenient on the small
13-inch macbook air display
and then going even further the imac has
even more advantages like having better
and louder speakers than the air
having a nice 1080p webcam compared to
720p
and having better quality microphones as
well and of course you have a wide
variety of color options with the imac
whereas the macbook air is limited to
more subtle colors
like space gray silver and gold so you
can see how the 24 inch imac definitely
has a few advantages over the air
but there's one very important thing
that the macbook has
that basically changes the entire
comparison
and that is portability unlike the imac
you can actually take the macbook air
anywhere and that
greatly improves its value since you can
now take it to a coffee shop to get some
work done
or even take it with you on vacation and
because of that portability
i'd say that the macbook air is going to
hold its value better than the imac
because there are much more people in
the market for a portable laptop
compared to a desktop computer for the
same obvious reasons
that i already mentioned so if you're
thinking about reselling your mac in a
year or two
the macbook air is going to be much
easier to resell
and you'll probably lose the least
amount of money in the process
and for those of you who really want a
desktop setup as well
you can buy an external monitor for the
macbook air to use at home
but keep in mind that if you want one
nearly as good as the 24 inch imax 4.5 k
display
you could be paying up to 700 for the
display alone
which is the price of lg's 4k ultra fine
display
which still doesn't quite match up and
keep in mind that those monitors
definitely won't look
quite as clean and premium as the
all-aluminum 24-inch imac
with its new modern redesign and that's
the beauty of the 24-inch imac since you
really get a lot of features and value
packed into that 1300 price tag and for
some use cases
the imac setup just makes more sense for
example
if you want a computer that your entire
family can access
the imac is perfect since you can have
multiple users
that log in by simply using the touch id
button on the magic keyboard and if you
have young children or teens
you can set up the imac in a central
living room or office location
where you can more easily monitor what
they're doing online
compared to a macbook which will be used
privately in a room
so with all that said there are
definitely good arguments for both the
imac
and the macbook but if we just
generalize it and try to figure out
which one
is the best value mac in 2021
i would 100 say that it is the m1
macbook air because of two reasons the
lower a thousand dollar or 950 price tag
and of course the huge benefit of
portability
which is much more convenient and it's
gonna help the resale value
for the future if you totally disagree
with me go ahead and comment your
thoughts below
but if you enjoyed this video click that
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you
in the next video